en corse lorsque la situation dégénère
et que les pompiers ne peut plus
contenir les flammes
les pélicans entre dans la danse
piloté par d'anciens militaires les
canadairs vol en formation bombarde
l'ennemi détecte des cibles dans des
zones difficiles d'accès
aux commandes de ces avions amphibies
les hommes et les femmes de la sécurité
civile ont appris à connaître les
dangers du feu et les pièges de la mer
exceptionnellement pendant plusieurs
jours nous avons pu filmer à bord de ces
machines volantes
[Musique]
nous sommes à la fin du mois de juin une
petite partie des équipages basée à
marignane prend ses quartiers d'été sur
le tarmac de l'aéroport d'ajaccio
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à partir de cet instant et à tour de
rôle les pilotes de canadair sont prêts
à décoller du lever au coucher du soleil
[Musique]
ce matin le chef de base olivier le
chevalier donne les instructions du jour
d'après les calculs des météorologues le
sud de la corse montre des signes de
sécheresse si le vent se lève toutes les
conditions d'un départ de feu seront
alors réunies l'endroit où la limite
en attendant l'alertent les futurs
commandants de bord doivent apprendre
les techniques d'éco page
autrement dit comment faire le plein
d'eau de mer avec leurs avions
alex va faire ses armes sur un plan
d'eau très particulier le golfe
d'ajaccio et ses environs on s'entraîne
en permanence pour être prêt en
permanence et là tout moment avec les
risques qu'il ya sur la corse la sirène
peu sonné et à ce moment là les avions
partiraient en moins de 15 minutes sur
le sur le feu cela fait quelques mois
déjà que daniel et alex forme un binôme
inséparable ancien pilote de la
patrouille de france
daniel va tester les réflexes de son
copilote mais avant de décoller les deux
hommes doivent absolument vérifier leurs
appareils
doit on aller on allait forte hausse
soit année pour taurina caf et ensuite
on vérifie ici les écopes les fameuses
et coop qui peuvent la vallée des
plongeurs donc la dimension
c'est une main donc on peut pas trop
rares les plongeurs voilà la légende qui
veut qui dit qu'on a retrouvé des
plongeurs au milieu d'une forêt donc
c'est pas ça marche pas
le moustache
on a passé à des moustaches ce sont des
déflecteurs quand on est allé copage on
alloue qui arrive donc par par ici et
qui vient buter là dessus et qu'ils
aient tous été reconduits vers l'arrière
ça évite de monter dans les moteurs on
peut on peut bien voir que quand un coop
ça peut partir directement dans les
moteurs parce qu'un moteur comme ça ce
nombre de russes à l'évidence et c'est
pas bon quoi bon regard de biais si le
ballonnet il n'a pas il n'a pas touché
un peu fort dans la ou quoi
alex est habitué au volant basse
altitude mais dans quelques instants
il va devoir composer avec les éléments
marins
[Musique]
les querelles et sur auto
maintenant encore descendre ensemble
coincé pendant le rapport
[Musique]
les personnes ok
autant dire que c'est parti
[Musique]
c'est la lecture du plan d'eau c'est à
dire qu'on regarde
les conditions tout
non
les récits pour faire un grand tour dans
12 des baigneurs des bateaux ou les
bouées défiler les écueils fait y avait
beaucoup de choses à voir parce que on
est obligé développer gamme est massée
près d'un côté ça s'apprend pas bonjour
il faut y aller tout doucement et acculé
accusé de connaissances et après
parce que trop de gens là en fait en
regardant vers le haut pour voir l'état
de la houle
là ce qu'on peut voir aujourd'hui avec
ça va être assez difficile puisqu'on à
la houle et dans un sens et on à le
manger à 90° de la houle
donc comme on est assez limité au niveau
de ce qu'on appelle nodules en travers à
bord on sait qu'aujourd'hui l'écho page
va être assainie
[Musique]
la terre est ce que c est ce que ces
pratiques avaient démonté une à léon
autant de points
cap sur le port d'ajaccio où la mer est
plus calme
alex entame son dernier virage avant la
plongée
[Musique]
les nouvelles recrues doivent
apprivoiser les mouvements de la mer
leur pire ennemi la houle qui peut à
chaque instant déséquilibrer la lourde
carlingue du canadair
[Musique]
avant de tout bord
entre
la lecture et robin parce que tu veux tu
peux pas bien le plan d'ottawa ne touche
rien n'est qu'un des volets marca le
canadair bombardiers d'eau se comporte
sur l'eau comme un bateau
en général sa coque ne fait qu'effleurer
la surface pour remplir ses soutes
il ne lui faut que 12 secondes pour
remplir ses deux réservoirs de 6000
litres
après une dizaine d'écopage dans le port
nos deux pilotes rejoignent la base ils
ne savent pas encore que leur repos sera
de courte durée
[Musique]
riquet dernier en corse les pompiers ont
dû intervenir sur plus d'une
cinquantaine d' incendies un peu partout
du nord au sud
ces feux ont été provoqués par la foudre
les feux de débroussaillage et bien
souvent par des incendiaires
cette fois l'alerté donnée dans les
environs de la commune de figari
[Musique]
lorsque le brasier est à portée des
lances à incendie les sapeurs pompiers
tentent comme ils peuvent de contenir
les flammes
[Musique]
mais souvent leurs réserves en eau
s'épuise vite obligé de battre en
retraite
ils font alors appel aux bombardiers
d'eau
au même moment sur le tarmac d'ajaccio 3
sonnerie retentit ça c'est le signal
d'un départ pour les équipages à
sécurité civile pour des raisons de
sécurité il est impossible pour nous
d'être présents à bord pour ce genre de
mission
mais grâce à nos caméras embarquées nous
avons pu reconstituer avec alex et
daniel les conditions réelles de cette
opération à figari pour ne pas perdre de
temps les réservoirs d'eau sont remplis
en début de piste daniel et alex ainsi
qu'un autre équipage met le cap au sud
ils doivent absolument éteindre le feu
naissant
et si le feu prendre l'ampleur on
rappelle des renforts du continent et
les parrains de se retrouver à 8 10
avions à travailler sur sur les feux de
corse et donc on a pour les hydravions
les amphibie on a l'habitude de dire
qu'on va essayer d'ouvrir un tuyau c'est
à dire on va écoper un endroit il argué
très près et sur le feu toutes les
une minute ou cinq minutes il va y avoir
6 tonnes d'eau qui tombe est comme ça
pendant trois ou quatre heures d'affilée
avant d'aller ravitailler dans la lutte
contre les incendies
chaque seconde est précieuse attisés par
des rafales de vent le feu peut menacer
les habitations donc voilà dépassés on
va penser mais déjà de loin de voir on
va voir le formule en arrivant sur le
jeu on va être prendre contact dès qu'on
arrive avec le convier qui va être admis
qu'un type le mans ça se passe au sol
quelles sont les bob stein
[Musique]
donc du vo
10 notre trajectoire qu'on s'est mis
d'accord avec le cos
c'est notre passé là en finale avant de
larguer on regarde bien qu'ils aient pas
du jeu m'ont bien fait pas des cannes
c'est aussi revoir pas toujours de zéro
côté du rio paris connait on change les
deux pilotes sont informés en temps réel
de l'avancée du feu et des conditions
météo
guidés par les hommes au sol et par le
cos le commandement des opérations
spéciales
ils ne doivent en aucun cas larguer
leurs charges sur les pompiers le
souffle d'une telle masse d'eau pourrait
être fatal
en pleine saison estivale les opérations
d'écopage sont toujours très risqué
les ports et les criques abriter sont
littéralement pris d'assaut par les
plaisanciers en tout genre on a encore
sorti un peu plus vers la sortie
il reste
résidu d'os
le feu de figari n'aura pas résisté
longtemps aux assauts répétés des
pélicans en moins d'une heure les
dernières fumerolles disparaissent du
paysage
[Musique]
cette année là la saison des feux en
corse aura duré plus longtemps que prévu
les grands incendies du mois d'octobre
au millénaire des équipages des canadair
à rude épreuve
malgré les conditions de vol périlleuse
des centaines d'hectares de forêt et de
maquis ont été sauvés
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le plus grand plaisir cavalaire je
dirais que c'est se poser sur loué sar
était comme un bateau on est en rapport
avec l'eau l'air la terre le feu
c'est un bon compromis
les hommes et les femmes de la sécurité
civile ne parle que très rarement du
danger pour eux il n'y a qu'un privilège
celui de voler sur des machines hors
norme
pourtant être aux commandes d'un
bombardier d'eau est certainement l'un
des métiers les plus dangereux du monde
en 50 ans
29 pilotes ont perdu la vie en opération